well not entirely because we knew the
Treasury hadn't done any modeling of
that sorted it had this very negative
approach and and used this model that in
in our view was completely inappropriate
and could only give them negative
conclusions really and so I wasn't that
surprised because it's difficult then
for a whole bureaucracy to come up with
a different way of looking at it that's
having having tried one way and found
really that it wasn't what the
government wanted to go with now luckily
for the government you have done some
analysis and your conclusion is that
falling back on WTA rules would be no
bad thing why do you say that because
the main thing about coming to WTO rules
is that you get rid of your tariffs or
you can get rid of your tariffs and
that's really the best strategy if we go
to WTO rules to to get rid of our
tariffs against the EU and against the
rest of the world and that brings us
huge gains because consumer prices fall
and that generates competition in the
economy which raises productivity so you
go double a double benefit from the
process the consumers are better off and
the economy is more productive and that
raises GDP on our calculations and
consumer welfare by about four percent
brings down prices by eight percent and
generates seven percent more government
revenue which which is obviously very
much worth having what happens under
that analysis if the UK doesn't cut
tariffs unilaterally after falling back
on WTO rules there is a scenario where
you don't cut tariffs you stay with the
current EU tariffs and you then you know
having not got a deal with the EU you
you can either decide not to have
tariffs on them which is the unilateral
option and then you don't have tariffs
on everybody else or you can keep the
tariffs on and do what we would call
tit-for-tat and have a sort of a trade
war effectively with the EU but then go
ahead rapidly and do free trade
agreements with the rest of the world
cutting tariffs on the rest of the world
and getting a lot of the gains from free
trade through trade with the rest of the
world under most scenarios then would
falling back on WTO rules be better in
your opinion than a free trade agreement
with the rest of the EU well you know
politically a free trade agreement the
rest of the EU is the course to follow
because you have good relations and you
can get lots of things sorted out so
clearly from a political viewpoint
that's the best thing to do and then it
can be followed by free trade agreements
with other countries and through that
route you can get to the same free trade
aim that the government has you know in
the longer term
I mean maybe to take a few years but
until it's politically that's a very
attractive option because it preserves
goodwill on all sides economically
you're actually better off with the WTO
option of going immediately to free
trade as as or as fast as you can
because that brings the gains of free
trade on sooner and more quickly so no
deal is better than a deal almost
economically no deal is better than deal
but politically obviously a deal makes a
lot of sense and you know clearly that's
the preferred option